six one seven eight three zero 4750 why
don't we try the two one zero area code
two one zero is one of those that it can
go a couple different ways depending on
who it is where is that I think two one
zero San Antonio maybe were you from two
one zero
hello yeah that's Andrew
I am from San Antonio Texas which you
were correct
thank you today to ask you oh sorry yeah
good um okay thank you I wanted to ask
you you're really pushing for voting for
November my question to you today is how
do you encourage people to go out and
vote but in particular the people who
probably don't i'm engage in like I
guess our culture most of people who
struggle um I guess not look for doing
it for like on engaging in our culture
yeah and maybe mostly people who just
don't like speak English because a lot
of like English is not R or like our
national language it's just very common
so and I know that in Texas a large
portion of Texas is made of Mexican
American people too so my question to
you is how would you reach out to them
how would I reach out to Spanish
speakers and get them to vote is that a
question yeah mm-hmm because there are
as much of American as we are of course
and you know it's boots on the ground
right it's what you've got to go and
talk to people and you have to
understand that every community is
different so when you see for example
some states reduce sunday voting hours
early voting hours before elections who
does that impact well it impacts in some
states it's designed to impact black
churchgoers who are going to vote
disproportionately Democratic because
you understand some of the culture
around black churches and getting
together and going to early voting for
example right as an example so in the
same way that voter suppression tactics
try to consider culture and individual
communities if we're trying to get
mexican-american Texans to go out to
vote you have to understand how to reach
out to them right and whether it's
community spaces religious spaces more
people doing get out the vote who speaks
Spanish better being able to communicate
why the issues that are on the ballot
are going to disproportionately or
acutely impact those communities it's
there's no one answer to your question
it's about you've got to figure out what
it is for any particular community that
will get them to go out and vote and I
think it's also important just to make
sure people understand that their vote
matters and it's really easy you you
often hear this talking point
how often are elections decided by one
vote almost never so my vote doesn't
make a difference and that is logically
fallacious and the way you fight against
that is you say you're right
elections aren't often decided by one
vote but they often are decided by fewer
votes than the number of people who know
who don't vote because they question the
value of their vote so one vote might
not make a difference but you could have
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people who say because it's
never decided by a vote I'm not gonna go
and if a hundred thousand people apply
that same logic collectively they could
now swing the election so it's really
important to be equipped to counter that
one vote doesn't make a difference so
why should I bother narrative and that's
that's more general than the Mexican
American Texan population but you've got
to get boots on the ground and
unfortunately the right is very good at
this okay well thank you very much all
right very much appreciate the call that
is going to do it for calls this week I
apologize to the more than dozen people
who are still holding sorry we couldn't
get to you we will take calls again and
I look forward to hearing from you next
time